or tiens bonne nouvelle pour vous
francesca je vais vous mettre de bonne
humeur vous avez été très sympathiques
avec moi concernant la mode oui je vais
envoyer renvoyer la pareille la lettre
au canada non non mais pas si bien dire
car selon bourdin direct les français se
marierait de plus en plus tard ça vous
laisse une petite marge
c'est ce que je veux dire regardez 227
mille mariage hétérosexuel en france en
2010 7 36 ans en moyenne pour les femmes
38 ans pour les messieurs ce sont
toujours les hommes qui sont plus âgés
que leurs épouses
selon les derniers chiffres de l'insee
alors bonne nouvelle oui j'y crois
encore dit notre amie lara fabian
ouais tant qu'on est vivant tant qu on
est mort on y croit encore au tendon
bref non mais évidemment c'est positif
mais moi maintenant je me dis que ça
peut m'arriver jusqu'à 85 90 ans
j'ai simplement envie de me marier et je
déteste les gens qui crachent sur
l'institution du mariage tu dises que
c'est pas cool
c'est génial on en reste là bas vous
avez là à votre droite
thibaud vézirian qui lui n'est pas du
tout fan du mariage est peu mais c'est
normal parce que je vis dans l'air du
temps
le mariage c'est has been c'est terminé
on a le droit de faire des super grosse
soirée à vue ne voulait pas dès le
morceau avec vous et je veux en effet
pour ça non ça c'est sûr que non parce
que déjà 2 qui dit mariage divorce donc
déjà pourquoi envisager un mariage donc
ça sert uniquement à faire des papiers
on peut très bien les avoir avec le pacs
et surtout une belle soirée avec des
vrais amis avec quelques membres de la
famille mais pas tous on pouvait voir
peut-être bord d'un bâtiment dans le
monde en a pris pour son grade d'accord
surtout pas d'accord très bien oui
c'était thibault oui les radins parce
que il faut dépenser des sous il faut
que tu épouses et dans autre chose que
le mariage pourquoi le mariage
absolument que ce n'est pas en fait
marié banier femmes
maintenant il est bon là c'est une femme
qui est au bout du rouleau plus plaisir
et pourtant quelle raison d'après vous
aussi l'âge a reculé parce que justement
ça coûte cher de situation alors premier
point voilà il faut avoir une situation
et surtout le mariage c'est un nid à
emmerdes
je suis moi je restais la jeune femme
fragile à la table je vais mesurer vos
propos sur le mariage sur rêve de mariée
avec ma moitié depuis on est fiancé
depuis sept ans le projet il faudrait
peut-être te passer la nuit c'est qu'au
moment de l'organisation qu'est-ce qui
se passe eh ben on s'embrouille soyons
tous les couples que ça va vous suivez
en valais on a gagné mariage l'autre qui
veut un grand maillage match il va en
réalité tata jeanine et en fait non tata
jeanine et plus encore
est-ce qu'on peut pas lâcher du lest ils
sont ailleurs bah non parce qu'en fait
banon elle mais si moi j'ai pas réussi
ça fait sept ans qu'on est fiancée on
n'a toujours pas trouvé de solution et
on n'est jamais marié pardonnez-nous et
des plats ne vous et vous vous engagez
pas ok alors comme vous la connaissez
bien vous allez gérer mais qu'est ce que
ces exilés pour vous le mariage ça se
résume l'un pour dépenser du pognon
l'aude pour faire une fête pour se
sécuriser le mariage en fait c'est un
contrat social moi j'ai lu plein de deux
fois l'acte de mariage 20 ans
[Applaudissements]
il est là tuez pas les équipes se
doivent fidélité secours et assistance
ils s'obligent à une communauté de vie
ils partagent l'argent à communauté
gaffe c'est un combat social après le
reste n'a rien contre eux mais c'est
aussi nommé shape team regarde dans la
même direction se dit sa peau non mais
sérieusement franchement on aime l'amour
ici ou bien tu vas pas tout [ __ ] en
l'air pour tata jeanine c'est pour ça
que je me marie pas parce que je peux
[ __ ] en l'air mon couple chabal je moi
j'ai une idée
voilà voilà on va prendre francesca
comme holding planneuse alors vous allez
vous marier dans l'année
vendant curé toutes les deux minutes
d'action que penser de cet âge du
mariage qui reculerait est ce que c'est
une bonne nouvelle c'est symptomatique
de notre société certains ne veulent
plus marié do est donc finalement isced
mais à mesure d'autres ont jamais voulu
d'argent éventuellement ou alors on se
dit que finalement ce serait synonyme
d'engueulades faites moi plaisir
répondait bien puisque francesca bordel